de vuelta a su tierra natal luego de
cuatro largos años de estar secuestrada
sophie persona recibió una bienvenida
que normalmente es para los dignatarios
extranjeros en el momento en el que se
bajó del avión en el sur de parís ella
llegó con su hijo sebastián y el
presidente de francia de manuel majo lo
saludó junto con otros miembros del
gobierno
pero nada fue liberada el jueves junto
con el líder opositor de malí suma las
hice en cuanto ella se bajó del avión en
la capital de mali bamako cayó en los
brazos de su hijo quien únicamente se
arrepiente de no haber hecho más por
liberarla
él
y si lo mejor que pude
pero hiciste lo que pudiste hiciste lo
que necesitabas pero no fue suficiente
[Música]
no te dije nadie es perfecto en este
mundo
la mujer de 75 años quien dirigía una
organización para huérfanos fue
secuestrada por los yihadistas en mali
en 2016 liberada junto a otros tres
retenidos persona fue la última francesa
secuestrada en todo el mundo ella le
dijo a los periodistas en bamako que
planeaba ir a francia oa suiza en un
tiempo cercano pero eventualmente espera
regresar a mali para continuar con su
trabajo de caridad